[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENGAMEH REZAEI: Karolis,
what are you doing?
KAROLIS DINEIKA: I'm
trying to figure out
how I can automate all my lamps
and devices without manually
configuring each one.
HENGAMEH REZAEI: Oh, I
have a solution for you.
Just build some digital twins.
KAROLIS DINEIKA: What's that?
HENGAMEH REZAEI: A digital
twin is like a digital version
of your physical devices.
Let me show you how to build
one on Google Cloud Platform.
KAROLIS DINEIKA:
That sounds awesome.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENGAMEH REZAEI: The solution
we build today looks like this.
The blue boxes are
managed products,
which we can use directly.
The only places where we
need to write our custom code
are the two yellow boxes, which
are Cloud Functions that links
IoT and Pub/Sub with Firestore.
KAROLIS DINEIKA: So all the
infrastructure will be managed,
and we are just writing
some custom glue
to fit the pieces together.
HENGAMEH REZAEI: Yes.
Let me show you the code.
For this project, we need
to have IoT Core set up.
You can find it in the console.
I have created a registry, which
is a grouping of IoT devices.
Under it, I have
gateway devices,
where our simulated
IoT device will be
talking to the gateway device.
As you can see here, I
have my simulated device,
called lamp1, bounded
to the gateway.
You can find a device by
clicking on devices as well.
Once the lamp is connected, then
it will send events to IoT Core
every second.
On event update, the event
will be sent from IoT Core
to Pub/Sub, and Pub/Sub triggers
the event to Cloud Functions.
I also have another
function applying changes
from the user to the device.
Let's look at the code.
I use the device ID as
my reference for changes,
reading changes from Firestore
and eventually updating
the device with the latest info.
Now, let's look at
the Firebase side.
I made a collection of
devices with different states,
like ON and OFF.
I also added the mode field
for brightness of each lamp.
So now, in Cloud
Shell, I run my code.
See what's happening
in Firestore?
I have added my
lamps, so you can
see the index is increasing
while each one is
sending their data
to IoT and Firestore.
Let's change the mode of the
lamp, assuming you have an app,
and change it through that,
but I changed it here manually
to soft.
The lamp mode immediately
changes to soft.
This change is real time and
quickly handled by Firestore
for you.
This is how you can build your
own digital twin solution.
Try the lamps!
[CLAPPING]
KAROLIS DINEIKA: Wow, it works!
HENGAMEH REZAEI: Yes, indeed.
Try out IoT Core and Firebase
for yourself at the link below.
KAROLIS DINEIKA:
And don't forget
to subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[CLAPPING]
[MACHINERY CLANKING]
As simple as that.
Not even a compile error.
HENGAMEH REZAEI: Now,
not even a compile error.
[MUSIC PLAYING]